michael is with us in philadelphia hi
Michael how are you hey Dave thanks for
helping me screw my head on straight no
troubles here's my question
I have $25,000 that I want to gift to my
niece which is proceeds from the
life-insurance policy
I'd like to maybe write a check directly
to student loans you know to eradicate
20 mm of student debt and I'd like to
tie 3,000 of it to the successful
completion of Financial Peace University
so my question is how religiously is
Financial Peace University and how can I
do this without her resenting me for
being the controlling jerk that I know I
am well how was your relationship with
her I very distant and and her dad hates
my guts my brother and so there's a lot
of strange thing and why is it your
writing why is it your writing her
checks if she's distant and her dad
hates ugh is it
this is proceeds from when my mom passed
away and I know that so she would have
wanted me to do so I was kind of
executing that the money is showing
basically no matter what we do it's not
going to be appreciated by him I'm
probably not but well she'll probably
appreciate the money or the debt but we
I don't pretend that this is going to
make a close relationship but I like not
to make it worse okay well I mean the
thing is this um only to the extent you
can influence someone that you're trying
to exhibit care for them is the only way
that this gift is going to be
appreciated so I guess it could be
something like this you're on the phone
with her is she married no okay and is
the money in your name yes
and are you married yes okay so you can
give her 14 thousand and your wife could
give her 14,000 you cannot give her
25,000 yeah I've got split it over the
two years yeah I would work okay and do
that to you get her on the phone and you
say whatever her name is
your grandmother left money to me
and I have the sense that I'm supposed
to pass it on to you I didn't have a
direct instruction to do that but I want
to do that I'm going to do that in a way
that I think she would have done it
because I know how she thought and I
know how much she loved you and I think
she would want to see you out of debt
and I think she would want to see you
being wise with money because she was
wise with money and so as an act of love
from your grandmother I'm going to offer
you $25,000 towards your student loan
debt plus 3000 and in order to do that
you need to go through this class but I
think your grandmother would have wanted
you to go through because I think it's
going to be helpful to you and kind of
bad guy off a grandma a little bit but
our good guy off a grandma you know
because now is what I is what I just
said would that be accurate yeah she was
a teacher and I and she was terribly
upset about how her my brother is so bad
with money always living under financial
duress and beyond her means and so
without worrying this girl's dad under
the bus in the conversation just go you
know grandma was always worried about
people that didn't handle money well and
she would want you to be wise and if you
will demonstrate wisdom by going through
this class I will make this gift to you
in her memory if you're unwilling to do
that then I don't know if it's what
grandma would have done and I'll have to
think about it some more I love the way
all that sounded I'm even you some of
those phrases exactly verbatim if you
don't mind I don't mind a bit because
it's all about caring for her yeah and
it's not about manipulating her and
you're not being a control freak because
you're really not you're trying to be a
blessing mm-hmm and you know when you
give someone something they can't
control it's not a blessing it's a curse
so if she's you know she's doing cocaine
and you get out of debt then it helps
her do more cocaine
you didn't bless her right she's out of
control I'm being I'm exaggerating but
miss handling money is misbehavior as
well okay how about the religious from
the
of it she's Jewish is this and I don't
know if a church setting is going to
yeah well they're not if she's issue
practicing Jewish yeah okay then um it's
not like Jesus Jesus Jesus Jesus every
other thing but it is what the Christian
Bible says about money in other words
our New Testament and what my Orthodox
Jewish rabbi friend calls the Bible the
Old Testament what I call the Old
Testament Talmud
right and so I quote a lot from proverbs
which is common ground and a lot from
what I call the Old Testament which is
common ground but it's not a Bible study
it's a get out of debt because proverbs
22:7 says the borrower is slave to the
lender live on less than you make
because a foolish man devours all he has
it says in Proverbs it says stuff like
that now I do say Jesus in there and I
do talk about my relationship with God
and so but it's not like every day you
go in there and somebody's gonna be
Jesus in your face thing okay okay so
it's enough there that if you wanted to
be offended you could be offended but I
thank you so much I've got Jewish
friends that have gone through it and
I've got Muslim friends that have gone
through it but they didn't go through it
trying to be offended this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
Oh